And now the old scout master.
Here's something I found at Ask Andy.
If you're not familiar with it, go over and check them out online.
Ask Andy at the United States Scouts Service Project.
He said waiting for things to improve of their own accord
is like expecting an avalanche to divide and go around you.
Now you've got to roll up your sleeves.
You've got to make things better, don't you?
Hey, this is podcast number 183..
Everybody roll.
We packed up our canoe
And now we're flying across the lake.
We're going camping,
We're going camping.
Oh yeah,
We're going camping,
We're going camping.
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green
And I am just back, a couple of days ago, from a wonderful, wonderful week
up in Algonquin Provincial Park in Ontario, Canada, canoeing with our scouts.
We took 25 scouts in three different crews.
We had probably the best weather we've had, maybe in five or six years.
The mosquitoes were out and the mutes were all hiding.
but you can't have everything, because you know where would you put it all.
But we had a wonderful time up there.
And let me make a pitch to you:
If your scouts did not go on some kind of high adventure trip this year,
next year, 2014,. make it happen,
Just make it happen.
Go to ScoutMasterCGcom.
Look for a high adventure.
Read what we've had to say about that.
There's just you know what
You can do it.
You can absolutely do it.
Make it happen.
It's a great thing to do for your scouts
And you're going to have a good time too.
So let's take a look in the mailbag.
Wow, lots of mail from the past week.
Aaron is a Cub Master in PAC 252 in Hudson, New Hampshire,
And he wrote to say: first, love listening to your podcast.
I'm a newly asked- or some may say suckered in- Cub Master,
Even though you're talking about the Boy Scout part of the program.
I find much of your thoughts, many of your thoughts,
very useful in my approaches to working with Cub Scouts.
Do you have any recommendations for more Cub-specific podcasts?
I listen via Stitcher
And all the best shows I found stopped posting over a year ago.
Some of my best ideas have come from listening to yourself
and other podcasters.
Keep up the show and thanks.
Well, thank you, Aaron.
Thanks for being in touch.
So far as I know, I'm the only person who is publishing a weekly podcast.
You would not believe the amount of effort and time it takes
to put one of these things together.
I would love to be able to speak more to Cub Scouts
and to Cub Leaders,
And if there's anybody out there who thinks they've got a voice
and they have the experience and they would like to put in the time
and make a commitment to do it, let's get a Cub cast going.
The only one that I know of that is now regularly published
is the one that the BSA offers from time to time.
I know that there's a big backlog of podcasts
by the folks over at PTC Media that are still out there
and still available,
And you can find them on the web, PTC Media,
And that's my best advice to you.
But thanks for getting in touch, Aaron,
I really do appreciate it.
John Strohmeier is in Houston, Texas, with Troop 55.
And he writes in to say
thanks for putting all of this together.
I'm just getting back into scouting after taking about 18 years off,
And your site has been very helpful in getting my bearings
and finding other information.
It's also great to hear a voice that supports
the free range kids theory in Scouts.
I don't have kids yet, but that's the way my fiance and I want them to grow up.
I have two questions for you
One. I can only find the latest two episodes on iTunes.
Do I have to go to the site to download the others?
Let me answer that question first, John.
Yes, that's the way it works right now.
If somebody out there is an iTunes guru
and they want to help me get all of the backlog,
all 183 editions of the Scoutmaster podcast, on iTunes,
I sure would appreciate it.
Get in touch with me, Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
John's other question is:
I volunteered to be the assistant scoutmaster
dealing with the order of the arrow for our troop.
I've found some of the extra opportunities for Scouts in the order of the arrow.
There are high adventure OA trips
and awards that Scouts and Scouters can earn as a part of the order of the arrow.
Do you think using these opportunities as carats for Scouts
is the best way to motivate them? in the order of the arrow,
It seems like offering the opportunity and awards
with the advancement method of Scouting,
But I'd like to hear from you about this.
Well, yeah, I guess they could be carats.
I guess they could get more people involved in the order of the arrow.
But what is our point?
Why are we doing this
If involvement in the order of the arrow
is something that somebody really enjoys
and it's something that really lights them up
and it furthers the aims of Scouting. that's good.
Not everybody is going to be that way.
I've been involved with the order for many, many years,
sometimes much more actively than I am at present.
Sure, it's great to have all those opportunities out there
for Scouts to take advantage of.
Yeah, make sure they know about them.
If they take you up on it, make it happen for them.
And thanks for getting in touch, John,
I really do appreciate it.
Scott is from Troop 651 in San Marcos, California,
And he wrote in to say:
I was listening to one of your old podcasts
way back in the 30-somethings
when a scout master who wrote you
and was disturbed by his scout's lack of imagination
when it comes to cooking.
I had been seeing the same thing
for the past few months in our troop
and we came up with something
that at least helped motivate the boys
to challenge themselves and try something new.
One of our Scouts who was preparing to go
to staff NYLT recently
came up with an idea from his experience with the course.
What we did was announce that the patrol
at a fast-tasting dinner on an up-cutting outing
would win the Golden Spoon.
Be sure to make some echo sound effects
when you say this.
Thanks for the direction, Scott
The Golden Spoon.
So we started doing it
and we sent the judges around
on the Saturday night to sample
what the scout had cooked,
and the results were impressive.
I told them the winner would be announced
at our next troop meeting
and the senior patrol leader presented
a spray-painted serving spoon
they could hang on their patrol flag.
We don't plan on doing this necessarily every month,
but the patrol leader's council now has a tool
they can pull out a few times a year
to shake things up.
I'm not sure we're the first ones to do this,
but I thought this story was a good example
of how the Scouts can be creative
and apply what they learn
and possibly give others an idea
they can use to inspire some more ambitious cooking.
Well, thank you, Scott.
Thanks for being in touch
and it's a pleasure to try.
You may come up with an idea on your own.
You may come up with a similar idea of your own,
like a golden fork maybe.
We also heard
from Mike Frame
in the Isle of Palms, South Carolina,
with Troop 502..
He said: I found you a few months ago
and I really enjoy your website
and especially your podcast.
Working on my commissioner college project
and thought your listeners
could give me some feedback and suggestions,
I also have a website
entitled BSA High Adventure
and Summer Camp Guide.
It provides a list of counsel
and high adventure links for Scouts
and I'll have a link to that
in the post that contains this podcast.
Go check it out,
Get in touch with Mike Frame
down there in South Carolina
and let him know what you think.
Thanks, Mike, Thanks for getting in touch
and thanks for sharing that with us.
Well, as I noted before,
I'm meeting next week with a quart of honor
and there's lots and lots of work to do
with the Troop and the Venture Crew.
I'm sure everybody out there
is busily working on their preparations
for the fall
and basking in the afterglow,
shall we say, of summer camp
and high adventure trips.
So I have a couple of email questions
for this podcast
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
One,
Six,
Five, Four, Three,
Two, One.
Let's start the fun.
Write me a letter,
send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your
emails.
Here's an email question that came in
from Fred Glover
and he is in Glendale Heights, Illinois,
with Troop 351..
Clark, what's your opinion about Scouts
carrying cell phones on outings?
Well, Fred, cell phones
and similar electronic devices
are really just part
of the fabric of modern life,
I think. like a pocket knife
or a gas stove, they can be useful,
but they are also subject
to misuse. I asked my youth leadership
to set the standards of use
for them and the kind of etiquette
that one would need
if these are going to be taken along
on a camping trip or be at a scout meeting.
And you know, once we've done that,
we really have no big problems.
That's not to say that I
particularly like having cell phones
around, but it's not really something
to make an issue over.
I got to tell you I've tried that in the past
and it's a losing battle.
I stopped fighting and started working
with the Scouts on it and we're in a good
place with it. If we have cell phones
out on a camping trip or a meeting
or something like that, you know there's
just be courteous about using them.
Don't use them in the middle of somebody's
presentation or while you're in the middle
of an activity, and it
works out pretty well. So thanks
for that question, Fred,
and I hope that helps Mike
Sakura- I hope I got the last name right.
Mike is with troop 706
in Columbia, Missouri.
He said: in several posts you
refer to Scouts choosing their own
patrols. In one post you even describe
that it's a possibility of that being
a fairly fluid thing.
Can you provide some more details on
how that works? Do you allow boys just
to float between patrols? How does it
affect the ability of a patrol leader
to know who's in and who's not
leading their patrol? If it's
something more structured, how often do you
let the boys switch or realign patrols?
How do you avoid the problem of less
popular or more introverted
boys being left out?
Our troop has assigned patrols
to new Scouts joining each spring.
We traditionally
structure patrols by age group
and use older Scouts as troop guides
to train the new Scouts on their camping
and cooking. but especially at the older
level the boys behave as you suspect:
They're hanging out with their friends, not their patrols.
I'm taking over Scoutmaster this fall
and I want to start letting
at least the older boys
choose their patrols,
but I expect some resistance from adults.
so I'm looking for answers before I get
the questions. Thanks for all you do for
Scouting and for being such a great resource.
Well, thank you, Mike, thanks for your kind
words there and thanks for getting
in touch. When it comes to patrols
and patrol assignments and
the way that all that works,
let me ask everybody to step back for a moment
and ask: why do we even have
patrols to begin with? I mean, what's the point?
Scouting
has patrols?
because that's where
all the aims of Scouting are met,
Each Scout looking after
his fellow Scouts, the patrol looking after
the individual Scout. that's where it all happens.
Now put yourself
in your Scouts
shoes for a moment.
You're going to be working with your patrol
all the time, for fun, for achievement,
for challenge. You'll be camping and tenting
and cooking together. Who do you want
to do this? with
Your friends, of course.
That's probably why you join Scouts in the first place.
You want to do things like camping
and tenting and cooking
and being in competitions
and planning and
doing great stuff with your
friends. From our
perspective as adults,
we'd like to have perfectly balanced
patrols by age, rank and experience,
because we think this will make things
more efficient and manageable.
But our concentration ought to be
not on how
efficiently we can manage things,
but on the happiness of our Scouts,
because happy Scouts
get the work of Scouting done
in their own time,
in their own way.
Some patrols are going to be orderly
and slick
and operate to a very high
standard. Some are going to be a little
messy or chaotic,
They may be a little slow, they may be a little
fast, but our Scouts will be
happily doing the work of Scouting
regardless. Scouts aren't
interested in our organizational
charts. They aren't interested in our
idea of who they should be
associating with. As you noted,
they find their friends
and stay with them, no matter what
your chart says. So instead
of fighting that strong desire
to be with their friends, how about
if we capitalize on it? How about
if we talk to the youth leadership
and ask them how they'd like to form and manage patrols?
How about that?
Ask them, Don't tell them how to do it.
Ask them how to do it.
Talk to your youth leadership
and then step back and
see what they come up with.
Explain they mustn't leave anybody out
or make them feel as though nobody
accepts or likes them. That
deals with the question of boys
who may be a little introverted
or don't have a lot of friends within the troop
or who maybe have
problem behaviors, But explain
to your Scouts that they need to be included
just as much as anybody else and that
they have a fantastic
opportunity to exercise
the Scout Oath and Law
by working on bringing
out that introverted Scout
or befriending the Scout nobody else
seems to like. That's really
what it's all about, isn't it? Now
step back and
respond to what they do.
Don't tell them what to do, necessarily.
Just respond to what they do.
Ask them how things are going, if they think
that the arrangements they have made
are working or if they could be
improved on. Protect them
from bossy, interfering adults who want
to tell them what to do and how to do it.
Let them lead, Let them
decide and work with them.
And are you going to encounter resistance
from adults about this? Well, of course you are.
You're going to encounter resistance from adults
about a lot of things. as a Scoutmaster,
And you know what.
You've got a patch on your
shoulder that says Scoutmaster, and
if they would like to have it and they would like to
arrange things according to their tastes
and their lights, Well they can
have the patch right. Otherwise,
they can stand by
and they can support your work
and support what you're doing with the troop.
Now, none of this advice
is intended to create
meaningless anarchy.
You have to train your Scouts
to understand the aim of Scouting.
as you go along, You ask
lots of questions, Observe
rather than participate, and watch
carefully for positive actions
within the patrols
that you can congratulate them on.
Scoutmasters aren't really Managers.
We're more like Gardeners: We pull the weeds,
We keep away the pests, We supply
a safe, well-watered place
for Scouts to do the work
of Scouting and to grow into useful, happy,
contributing adults.
and it's really that simple.
Work with them on this,
ask them what their solutions are
and help them shape something that
everybody's going to like and, most
importantly, gets the work of Scouting
done. Mike, thanks for getting
in touch again and I hope that helps.
Don Ross is with Troop
261 in Castle Rock, Colorado,
and he says
thanks for the truly valuable insights.
I love the podcast that I'm currently
mining the blog and
stealing nuggets for my own use.
I'll gladly pay you in coffee, gorp
and campfire ashes from my Scoutmaster
pension fund
should our trails ever cross-
and I hope they do. Well, I do too, Don,
and I'll take the coffee and the gorp
and the ashes any old day.
I have been involved in Scouting
for a long time. I have
three sons, two of whom are Eagle Scouts
and the third is just winding
up as life requirements. Our current
Scoutmaster will be stepping down in December
of this year and I will be taking
over. over the years Our troop leadership
has kind of swung back and forth: from being mostly
adult, led more or less
like an advanced Cub Scout pack,
to being very youth led
with varying degrees of adult guidance,
sometimes great, sometimes less
than great. My desire for my tenure
as Scoutmasters to guide them
into that golden
balance where the adults are present,
engaged and necessary, but the boys
are the ones running the troop.
in a recent podcast you listed
three conditions you require for any
activity that the Scouts
plan References were
directly related to the patrol method
in the game of scouting. I am
scouting your blog to find those references
but I haven't found any directly yet. You
put the requirements very eloquently in the podcast
and I want to employ them
in our upcoming planning session
and I'd also like to know what
the best primer is on the fundamentals
of the classic patrol method.
I really want to engage
my patrol leaders council in this
immediately and need to ensure I'm
adequately equipped to help
them handle it. Well, Don,
thanks for the kind words.
I really appreciate you getting in touch.
most of the answers you are
looking for are going to be found in the
book Working the Patrol Method.
I will have a link on how to
find that book in the post that contains
that podcast. but Working
the Patrol Method- it's available on Amazon.
and
the rest of the answers you're going to
find from the experience of
just trying things out
and making things work. The big plus,
the biggest part of the answer,
is in the fact that you
understand that it's your job
to enable the boys to make sure that these
things happen. That's, follow the advice
and working the patrol method and you'll
get off on the right foot. and
congratulations and thanks
for taking on the job as
Scoutmaster. You can get in touch
with me with a question or a comment
and you're going to find out how to do that in just
a moment.
Well, thank you for listening
to this edition of the
Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Go to
scoutmasterscgcom
to read the Scoutmaster blog
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email.
or you can
go to scoutmastercom
to read the Scoutmaster blog
and while you're there. you can
receive updates to the blog by email.
you can subscribe to this podcast,
the Scoutmaster Podcast, on iTunes
when you do leave a comment
or review or a rating. if you have the time,
it's always appreciated. You can also
access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
you can get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
you can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
tweet ScoutmasterCG
on Twitter
and you can watch us on YouTube.
that's right, we're
at the ScoutmasterCG channel
on YouTube. and for those of you on Google Plus,
we do have the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle.
just search for us on Google Plus.
if you're not fascinated
with the vast panorama of social media,
roll into the late 90s
and send me an email.
right, you can send your comments and questions
and your wild ideas to Clark
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
it remains only
for me to tell you
that the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
nope, it's just me.
I've got a microphone
and a web account
and a little spare time
to try and help scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here's our
founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pel.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and Group Camping
Why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone,
you.